If you're learning a language,
try live online lessons with I talk he'd
use today's technology to take lessons
conveniently from home by one lesson and
get one free lincoln description.
Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul.
Today's topic is how similar our French
and Italian,
well they're actually very similar.
They share a lot of common vocabulary
and the grammar is very similar but in
terms of phonology they are quite
different.
So in their spoken form they are
generally not mutually intelligible.
French and Italian are both romance
languages.
They both developed out of the vulgar
Latin spoken throughout the Roman
empire,
but French kind of stands out as
different from other romance languages.
The historical land of goal is located
inside Modern Day France and one theory
is that when the Roman empire conquered
Gaul and tried to force the local
population to speak Latin,
they spoke at using golish speech sounds
and that has affected the phonology and
the pronunciation of French.
Until this day goldfish was a Celtic
language.
So that means that there is some Celtic
influence in the French language,
specifically in phonology and any case,
French and Italian are very closely
related.
Let's have a look at just how close they
are.
Vocabulary,
Italian and French are very similar in
terms of vocabulary.
The lexical similarity of the two
languages is 89% that means that 89% of
the words used have equivalents or
cognates in the other language.
That doesn't mean the words are exactly
the same,
but they are clearly related.
Some obvious examples,
Valenzuela,
bon Jordan'll until the song into the
Sunday mosaic,
monae,
Jada,
and there are some less obvious cognates
to or be dull or medallia order Akella,
[inaudible] Yada Shelf Shit.
She had a car.
Then I think the figure of 89% is
probably true if we include formal
literary vocabulary,
but in daily conversation that seems to
be a little lower.
Let's look at these examples.
Maquila to have Aaliyah,
avn,
ecomaine,
Cucina t prep,
our own cafe,
Msi,
Sita Valisa,
viansa vic McDonald cuisine is you're to
play pound coffee.
So here you can see that most of the
words have an equivalent except for the
words that are in red.
Those ones are different,
like the word for here in Italian it's
queen and in French it's see and that
were four width.
In Italian it's con and in friendships
Avec the word for Ian in Italian,
it's in and in friendships don't,
aside from those words,
the other words are all basically
equivalent except for a couple of
definite articles which are used
differently.
I recommend that you pause the video now
and look at the two sentences along with
an English breakdown and see what you
notice about the equivalents.
Here are another couple of examples in
nondomestic rtd and Entrada in an
[inaudible] in nuclear power,
don't weight loss a magazine,
the ceramic,
so again,
these sentences are quite similar,
but a few of the words are different.
The mentee,
Kathy,
that means forget in Italian and who
bleah means,
forget in French.
And again,
we see the different words for in the
Italian word in and the French word
don't.
And we see different words for store,
the Italian word,
niggled steel and the French word
magazine.
So again,
why don't you pause the video and have a
look at the two sentences and see what
you can learn by comparing them.
So you can see that in a typical
sentence.
The majority of vocabulary used is
similar to the vocabulary used in the
other language,
but not all of it.
Grammar in French and Italian,
the word order and the sentence
structure are generally very similar.
Here's a simple sentence to show.
Similar would order.
This sentence means I have a newspaper
for the trip.
He Oh and John anally pedal viaggio j on
[inaudible].
And you can see that these sentences are
word for word translatable.
Hmm.
But there are also some grammatical
differences too.
In French subject,
pronouns are consistently used,
but in Italian subject,
pronouns generally aren't used except
for emphasis.
So in French you ship out lonely.
In Italian you will following lazy but
yo is not usually said so which just
paddling glazer and there's another
difference in pronouns in French.
The second person,
formal end plural pronoun is in Italian.
The third person Pronoun Lei is used for
the second person formal.
So when French we'd have [inaudible]
toll on tomorrow,
but in Italian [inaudible] so the
Italian sentence is like she speaks too
slowly,
but it should be clear from the context
that you are seeing you and not she
because you're talking to someone
directly.
Also in Italian direct object pronouns
are also normally attached to the end of
a verb.
When it's in the infinitive form.
In French we'd have shoveled day,
but in Italian we'd have eal volume.
Rollo negotiation is also a little
different.
In the two languages.
In French we'd say Jeanette backlit
phone,
glee with no end path to show negation.
But in Italian we'd say eo known
paddling,
Lazy.
So in French we have no and pop,
but in Italian there's no equivalent of
Po.
Those are some little differences.
But other major things like the verb
tenses are basically the same.
French and Italian.
Share the same 14 verb tenses.
Of course,
they're not conjugated exactly the same,
but the tense is function in the same
way.
For example,
let's look at how the past tense is
formed in French to a mosaic.
Elka shows in Italian too.
I'm on Jato quelled Coza.
This means you ate something spoken to
one person informally.
The verb consists of two parts.
First,
the second person,
singular form of the word for have and
second the past participle.
Obviously the forms are different,
but the way you use them together to
create the past tense is the sin.
And just as a quick side note,
notice how to say something in the two
languages.
Kelika shows versus qual.
Coza,
French and Italian grammar is very
similar,
just like the vocabulary is largely
similar pronunciation.
The biggest difference between French
and Italian and the one that prevents
mutual intelligibility the most is
pronunciation.
Italian pronunciation is mostly phonetic
and mirrors the written words.
Exactly.
French words are pronounced from the way
they're written,
and you have to keep some phonetic rules
in mind when pronouncing words.
Most Italian words end in a vowel,
which makes it easy to pronounce the end
of the word.
In French,
there are many consonants that are
usually silent at the end of a word.
For example,
this sentence meaning the weather is
cold in Italian [inaudible] in French in
fifth squat.
Notice that the d sound at the end of
fall is silent.
Another example is the phrase for white
wine in Italian Vino Bianco in French.
Then blown here at the final C is
silent,
so the last song we hear is the nasal
sound represented by in van also ends in
a nasal sound.
The end is not pronounced as a consonant
here.
Instead that nasal aises the proceeding
vowel,
so rather than Van Blonde,
it's van blown.
There are also some other sounds that
are quite different than French.
For example,
the French are,
it's not the same as the rolled or that
you would find in Italian.
In Italian,
you produce the are by flapping the tip
of your tongue against the roof of your
mouth,
behind your teeth,
but the French are as a guttural are
that's produced at the back of your
mouth.
In Italian [inaudible] in French
bacteria.
So those final silent consonants as well
as the nasal sounds of the French are
south.
Those are some differences with Italian,
but there are also some of the things
that learners find challenging about
French pronunciation.
Let's finish by just breaking down a
couple more sentences and seeing what
similarities and differences we notice.
Here's the sentence,
meaning what are your favorite dishes in
Italian quality?
SONA,
we've lost [inaudible]D in French,
Kennison Ville,
Platte,
[inaudible],
la,
so word by word.
The sentence is what are your plural
dishes?
Plural.
Preferred quality and Ken are
equivalents.
But notice that the plural ending is
different.
In Italian,
it's often eat or act,
but in French it's a silent s Somol and
some are equivalents.
But notice that Somo ends in a vowel
while some ends in a nasal sound and a
silent t evos three invo are equivalent,
but in Italian,
the definite article is normally used
with a possessive pronoun like votes
three.
While in French there's no definite
article,
PRT and Pla or equivalent,
but notice the different plural endings
and notice that words with I and Italian
often have an l in French.
We've seen another example of that,
the uncle in Italian and blog in French,
but if fell,
Iti and pressure are obvious equivalents
just with different accent markings and
a different ending.
Now here's one more pair of sentences,
but this time I want you to have a look
at them and notice the similarities and
differences without me breaking it down
for you.
In Italian he knows three [inaudible] in
French and those,
I mean finish days unit.
So I hope this video has made it clear
just how similar French and Italian
really are.
The speaker of one of them can probably
learn the other quite easily and in
writing the level of mutual
intelligibility is quite high.
But because the cognate words are all a
little bit different,
and because of the pronunciation of the
two languages is so different,
the two languages are not mutually
intelligible in their spoken form.
But as a learner of Italian,
my previous knowledge,
French makes a lot of things in Italian
instantly clear to me.
So the question of the day for speakers
of French and Italian,
how similar do you consider the two
languages to be and to learners of
French and Italian?
Does your knowledge of one of those
languages help you make any sense of the
other or help you understand the other?
Share your experiences in the comments
down below.
Be sure to follow Lang,
focus on instagram,
on twitter,
and on facebook.
And again,
thank you to all of my patrion
supporters for continuing to make this
channel possible.
Thank you for watching and have a nice
day.
Okay.